what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the newest events in the
black clovers story and I will
especially be talking about some crazy
revelations that we got regarding hasta
and his demon and also what I believe is
the setup for a brand new arc in black
clover we can expect a lot more
world-building we can expect new
characters being introduced and we can
expect to learn more about hasta and his
anti magic I am definitely excited I
can't wait to break it all down right
here if you enjoyed the black clover
content on this channel you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell you can
also check me out on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar all the way it
is black clover news and updates and
finally this video will be dealing with
the latest developments in the story so
manga spoilers will be coming proceed
with caution you have been warned
chapter 216 picks up right after
Julius's shocking revelation from the
previous chapter and we see hasta
screaming and asking why is it that
either the clover kingdom will be
destroyed or he will end up dying at
this point Yami hilariously says the
Julius's predictions are always correct
and he wishes for Austin to rest in
peace
I thought that this was an absolutely
hilarious moment that breaks the tense
situation and it is one of the reasons
why I love Yami we've all been anxiously
waiting to see what julius meant when he
said that
hasta the protagonist of the story is
going to die and yet Yami finds this to
be a great time to make morbid jokes and
just mess around absolutely classic Yami
Julius goes on to confirm what we all
know by now that Austin's anti magic
comes from a devil the same type of
devil as the word magic devil that they
just defeated Yami then continues with
the comic relief by telling us that to
get away from him with his devil
nastiness julius explains that black
horns indicate that a person has used
forbidden magic and is connected to a
world separate from our own apparently
this is a curse known as veil or vague
and the reason why sucre has horns is
because she also used forbidden magic to
seal away the devil five hundred years
ago
oh the curse mixed with Sakura's unique
magic and this resulted in her being
able to transform into the bird Nero and
apparently Sakura can now transform into
neural at will Julius is very impressed
with Sakura's magic which Julius says is
different from normal transformation
magic rather than merely transforming
her body into the body of a bird
Sakura's body is actually sealed inside
the bird
Julius then follows up on his prophecy
about the cobra kingdom potentially
being attacked and destroyed by
neighboring kingdoms and he gives us a
bit more information about the three
neighbouring kingdoms the demon nation
is militant and a dabble in black magic
they even use human experimentation to
make their army stronger and we've
already seen some examples of that with
fauna and Mars and we know that the two
of them are mages from the Diamond
Kingdom who were experimented on in
order to make them stronger then we have
the heart nation which is neutral and
not a direct enemy of the clover Kingdom
but the heart nation is also rich in
natural mana and is largely unexplored
by foreigners the inhabitants of the
heart nation also have their own unique
style of magic which makes this nation
very mysterious and unpredictable and
finally we have the Spade nation to the
north now this is really interesting
because Julius calls this nation the
demon nation of spade and he also says
that by serving the ancient horror which
slumbers within the extreme bitter cold
of their massive land they have achieved
supremacy the Spade Kingdom is now
apparently expanding into the grand
magic zone that separates it from the
other kingdoms and now that the clover
kingdom has just gone through the
massive battle with the elves and the
magic Knights are exhausted the clover
kingdom is extremely vulnerable to
attack by a rival nation looking to
expand it really looks like we have
already entered a new arc in black
clover and this arc will focus on world
building and learning more about the
rival kingdoms and also on the demons
after all we just learned that Auster's
ability to use anti magic amounts to a
curse because this type of magic is
forbidden and it connects him to the
other world the world of the demons
I expect that the new arc will explore
this connection between asta his demon
and demon world in a lot more detail and
we are going to learn more about what
this curse actually implies is the curse
going to kill hasta bye progressively
harming him physically or is he going to
become a target for others to kill him
because of the curse I am very curious
to find out how this curse plot point is
going to be developed as the story
progresses but beyond Asta's demon and
assuming that the initial translation is
correct and julius really did call the
spade nation the demon nation of spade a
nation which serves the ancient horror
which slumbers within the extreme bitter
cold of their massive land then this
will have great importance in the future
why would Spade be called the demon
nation unless they've been experimenting
with demon magic and what is the ancient
horror that slumbers within the Spade
kingdom is it another devil is the spade
kingdom increasing its power by using
the magic of a devil in much the same
way that hasta has been using the anti
magic of his devil if this is the case
and the spade kingdom has some kind of
ancient devil on their side then we
could expect to see an epic showdown of
devil versus devil and if the spade
kingdom also has knowledge of the demons
and the Otherworld where the demons
reside and if they find out about hasta
and the 5-leaf grimoire they will surely
target hasta either they will try to
take control of the 5-leaf grimoire for
themselves or they will try to kill
hasta so he cannot become a threat to
them in the future at any rate I am very
interested to find out why exactly the
Spade kingdom is known as the demon
nation of Spade
let me know what you guys think about
this is the Spade Kingdom a kingdom that
worships an ancient devil and are they
going to become the next antagonist in
the series give me your thoughts down in
the comments at this point Julius
emphasizes that at a time like this the
clover kingdom cannot afford to lose any
of its magic Knights so this kind of
explains why in the previous chapter
Julius was so forgiving to William even
though many magic Knights were possessed
by elves and fought against their own
Kingdom during the previous arc now that
the kingdom is in serious danger of
attack from a foreign rival this is the
time for unity and not for division
Julius then goes on to say that a magic
Congress is going to be convened in
order to determine what just happened to
the kingdom why did so many mad
night's turn against the kingdom why did
all this destruction happen and so on
most of these are things that we as
readers are all fully aware of like the
elf reincarnation and the fact that the
devil orchestrated the elf massacre but
these things are not common knowledge to
the rest of the kingdom and they will
want to find out what actually happened
however the magic Congress is going to
be run by the royal house of Kyra and
they are infamous for treating commoners
as second-class citizens because of this
once they find out that there is a devil
residing with Anastas grimoire the magic
Congress may decide to blame
asta for everything and use him as a
scapegoat after all to them he is just
an expendable commoner and if they just
blame him for everything they can
reassure the people that the culprit has
been dealt with so there is nothing else
to fear or worry about after this we
jump to none other than Augustus Kiera
clover the king who has been protected
from the elves by the Loki strongest
character in the entire series and of
course I'm talking about the divine
dragon emperor second bronze Aza of the
green mantis squad i honestly have no
idea how the word magic devil was even
defeated without sec hey there on the
scene but now we finally figured out
what CEQA has been up to it turns out
sucky accidentally saved the king when
he was trying to run away from the elves
but now that the king is convinced that
ii save them ii milks it for all it's
worth
saying that it was all just a walk in
the park for the great warrior ii then
suddenly a bunch of mages and hooded
robes who claim to work for the eye of
the midnight sun show up and declared
their intention to take the king's life
the mages begin to attack as both the
king and ii are freaking out but then
someone else shows up this new
character's name is apparently damnatio
if we can trust the initial translation
and he is dressed as some sort of judge
he even holds the scales of justice in
his hands and he promises to judge the
anti-monarchist Nobles in the name of
the royal family and justice his magic
ability or one of his abilities appears
to be shrinking the mana of other mages
because he seemingly uses his scales of
justice to do just that he shrinks the
mana of the robe wearing attackers and
renders them virtually powerless the
fact that this guy was able to take out
a
bunch of mages at once on his own and
his unique power which appears to be
drastically weakening the magic
abilities of others make it clear to us
that this character is a very powerful
mage and that he is not someone to be
taken lightly
the final page tells us that this
powerful mage damnatio is coming for the
one who has been possessed by a devil
and that of course means that he is
coming after hasta my prediction is that
this guy will be the main judge of the
magic Congress and that he will be the
one who tries to escape both hasta and
blame him for everything that happened
with the elves and the devil he will
play the role of a zealous Inquisitor
and this whole magic Congress arc will
likely be a shorter arc that will lead
into a more epic arc and that will
probably be an arc that deals with the
rival kingdoms and with the Spade
Kingdom in particular if I had to bet I
would say that the fact that the Spade
nation is connected to demons means that
this kingdom is going to be the focus of
the next major conflict and the ancient
devil magic that apparently lurks within
the Spade kingdom will prove to be an
important component of the next major
arc I could be wrong and something else
could come up and take the story in a
totally different direction but this is
my personal guess at this point in time
but what do you guys think where will
the story go from here and do you agree
with me that the Spade Kingdom and their
mysterious demon connection is going to
play a significant role in the next
major arc also how do you think that
Auster's curse will affect him in the
future is the curse going to slowly harm
him from within or is something else
going on with this strange curse let me
know down in the comments if you enjoyed
this video you want to see more black
clover content on this channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you never miss a
new black clover upload feel free to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest anime
news and updates I want to give a huge
thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making our work possible a special thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
eldress and on Hell crews another
massive thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby Rey
in grata alone Adam Maddy Mac makoto-kun
and keelon and finally at the very
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness a
tier reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison and Lord
naksan or disciples of Lord we go
himself if you feel that our content
provides value for you when you want to
support more be sure to check out our
patreon link in the description even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]